donc modem démocrate et indépendant
merci madame la Présidente voilà nous
avons eu ce matin et en ce début
d'après-midi un débat riche et un débat
je pense qui fait honneur au travail
parlementaire
on avait la chance d'avoir deux
propositions de loi sur le même sujet
proposition de loi de Madame panot et
proposition de loi de Madame berger
quelque part ça nous a donné un temps de
réflexion de travail double temps en
commission et et un travail qui a pu
être fait avec une recherche de
consensus nous nous y sommes arrivés
l'amendement qui a été voté tout à
l'heure qui a un amendement
transpartisan a été voté dans tous les
groupes à la majorité sauf un les
républicains
dans l'ensemble des groupes
majoritairement tout le monde a voté ce
dispositif donc nous montrons par ce
vote notre capacité à travailler
ensemble quand les sujets réclament le
dépassement des clivages et je pense
vraiment que par ce vote par ce travail
nous en aurons le travail nous en aurons
lequel Parlement et nous donnons un
message aussi aux Français c'est-à-dire
que parfois au-delà de nos différences
au-delà de nos contradictions politiques
nous sommes en capacité d'aller dans le
sens
de la réponse la plus proche aux
préoccupations des Françaises et en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet aux
préoccupations des Françaises
notre texte est équilibré je le redis
par la définition de l'effectivité de
l'égal accès nous nous gravons dans le
marbre la possibilité pour les femmes de
bénéficier de pouvoir
avoir ce droit ce droit à l'IVG et le
terme
IVG il est inscrit dans le marbre aussi
et c'est une référence forte une
référence historique à la loi veille la
loi veille c'était justement ça à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et je le redis au républicains qui ont
un peu tremblé aujourd'hui comme ils
avaient majoritairement tremblé
d'ailleurs en 75 le
ce qui est écrit c'est interruption
volontaire de grossesse donc on laisse
évidemment
aux femmes la capacité la liberté de
choisir et c'est aussi ça que nous
apportons comme message après avoir
apporté un message aux Français par
cette capacité à travailler ensemble
nous apportons aussi un message au reste
du monde et cette loi est aussi une
réponse à la loi à la et aussi une
réponse à la décision de la Cour suprême
américaine dans notre pays nous
affirmons haut et fort que les droits
acquis par les femmes que les droits
acquis par les femmes et par les hommes
n'auront pas de régression et nous
continuerons le combat pour qu'elle
continue à avancer je remercie tous les
parlementaires qui ont travaillé sur ce
sujet aujourd'hui et les jours derniers
évidemment madame berger madame panot
madame rixin madame beltistel je vais en
oublier je madame bateau madame
je vais en oublier mais elle se
reconnaîtront merci à elle madame Elsa
fossillon
voilà est-ce que excusez moi
excusez moi mes chers amis le moment est
important laissez-moi aller jusqu'au
bout j'avais prévu de faire moins tout
mais si vous voulez je peux aller
jusqu'au 5 minutes donc pour conclure
nous en aurons le travail parlementaire
par ce vote et continuons le combat
parce qu'il n'est pas fini il faudra
acquérir il faudra aller chercher la le
vote des sénateurs et après j'espère que
le gouvernement pourra reprendre ça à
son compte pour un projet de loi et je
remercie évidemment monsieur le garde
des sceaux pour son avis de sagesse mais
une sagesse bien éclairée sur les débats
d'aujourd'hui